♪
T TD I TB/R
TTIN "THSQUARIDE
M COER ROGS ALOSIDEHE
GENDY GG IVORY.
CHRISTMAS IS AROUND THE CORNER.
I HEARD RUMORS YOU'RE IN THE
GIVING SPIRIT YET AGAIN.
>> CONNER, I GOT THE GREEN ON,
IT'S NOT RED BUT IT'S GREEN.
CHRISTMAS IS RED AND GREEN.
I GOT THE GREEN ON.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW
GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
I'M LOOKING FOR TAKES.
LOOKING FOR TAKES.
I SEE -- ACTUALLY JAKE STON SAYS
TOM BRADY FOR MVP.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> WE'LL GET INTO THAT A BIT
LATER.
FOR NOW, HOPEFULLY YOU WOULD
HAVE RODE WITH US LAST WEEK.
"THE SQUAD RIDE" CASHED YET
AGAIN.
IT'S BEEN A BANNER YEAR.
FOLLOW ALONG.
MAKE SOME MONEY AND HAVE SOME
FUN.
THIS IS THE SHOW WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR LOCKS TO GET IN THE
END ZONE.
WE ASK YOU EVERY WEEK ON SOCIAL,
IN THE APP, WHO IS SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY?
HERE'S THE TOP PICKS YOU SENT US
FOR THE WEEKEND'S SLATE.
TYREEK HILL AT THE TOP WITH
CORDARRELLE PATTERSON, DAVANTE
ADAMS.
HEAVY WIDE RECEIVER BOARD TODAY
AND ONE FORMER WIDE RECEIVER AND
RUNNING BACK IN PATTERSON.
ADAMS AND CEEDEE LAMB.
HOLLYWOOD DROWN.
AND TOM BRADY RUSHING PLUS 650?
>> TOM BRADY?
>> FEELING CRAZY TODAY.
TOM BRADY?
HIS MVP ODDS ARE WAY BETTER THAN
THAT.
I'M EXCITED TO GET INTO THIS.
BEFORE WE DO THAT, LET'S LOOK AT
OUR FAVORITE LOCK LEGEND VIDEOS
NOT FEATURES FROM LAST WEEK.
>> WHAT'S UP, "BLEACHER REPORT,"
WE'RE BACK HERE WITH ATLAS,
TODAY --
>> I'M DETERMINING WHO I WILL
PICK THIS WEEK TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN.
>> IT'S MY DECISION DAY ON WHO
WILL SCORE AN ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
IN WEEK 14.
>> YOU READY?
>> THIS WEEK WE'RE HAMMERING --
>> TRAVIS KELCE.
>> DALLAS GOEDERT.
>> WE'LL GO WITH MYLES.
>> MILES JEFFERSON, ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN.
>> GREG, LET THEM KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GIVING AWAY TODAY.
>> I'M NOT ONLY GIVING OUT
HOODIES, I'M GIVING AWAY TWO NFL
JERSEYS.
ONE GOES TO THE WINNING LOCK
LEGEND AND ONE GOES TO A LUCKY
COMMENTER LIKE YOU.
DON'T GO NOWHERE.
STAY TUNED IN UNTIL THE END OF
THE SHOW, THAT'S WHEN I'LL GIVE
IT OUT.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, YOU GUYS
WANT A JERSEY, YOU GUYS WANT A
HOODIE, I NEED GIFS AND EMOJIS,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I NEED
WINNERS ONLY PLEASE, CONNOR.
WINNERS ONLY.
>> LET'S DO IT.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL.
THE LAST ONE STANDING IS OUR
SQUAD RIDE LEADER.
THOSE ODDS WILL GO SOMEWHERE.
LET'S GET IT GOING.
FIRST PICK OF THE DAY COMES FROM
H. BOWERSOCK.
TELL US WHO IS SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
>> QUICK, BEFORE THEY FIND ME,
WHAT YEAR IS IT?
>> 2021.
>> MADE IT JUST IN TIME.
THE LOCK OF THE CENTURY, IT'S ♪
HAPPENING THIS VERY WEEKEND WITH
ALL THE MONEY YOU HAVE, RYAN
TANNEHILL ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
PLAYING THE GARBAGE JAGUARS.
WITH ALL THE MONEY YOU HAVE,
RYAN TANNEHILL ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN.
>> FBI, OPEN UP!
>> THEY FOUND ME.
>> THE TIME TRAVEL LEGEND.
I'M NERVOUS FOR HIM NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THAT ANXIETY, BUT THE
FACT THAT HE PICKED RYAN
TANNEHILL PLUS 310.
SEEMS LIKE A BOLD DECISION TO
KICK THINGS OFF.
BEFORE WE GET INTO THAT
DISCUSSION, LET'S SEE WHO HE'S
UP AGAINST.
DECISION TIME, SECOND PITCH
COMES FROM NUMERO 25, THE
G.O.A.T.
LET'S SEE THE CHOICE.
>> FIRST OFF, SHOUT OUT TO THE
B/R BETTING APP AND INSTAGRAM
FOR THE PARLAY TOMORROW,
ANY-TIME SCORERS.
BEING I'M FROM DALLAS, I HAVE TO
ROCK WITH MY BOY, CEEDEE LAMB.
LET'S GET IT!
COWBOYS NATION, BABY!
>> THE COWBOYS COULD USE HIM IN
THE TRECHBNCHES.
THEY NEED HIS ENERGY.
WE HAVE THE TIME HILL TRAVELER,
RYAN TANNEHILL AND CEEDEE LAMB.
HOW DO WE FEEL ABOUT THESE TO
KICK OFF THE SHOW?
>> CONNOR, UH, THE RYAN
TANNEHILL PICK, I DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO START.
>> HE'S SPEECHLESS.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I'M WILLING
TO LAY MY MONEY ON IT.
WHAT WE CAN DO ON THIS SHOW, WE
COULD PROBABLY BOOST THE ODDS UP
SOMEWHERE TO WHERE WE NEVER
BOOSTED ODDS UP TO BEFORE.
WHERE I'M FROM, WE LIKE TO SAY
I'M COOL, WE DON'T LIKE THE
DUDE.
I'M COOL, CONNER.
I'M COOL ON RYAN TANNEHILL.
WE CAN TALK CEEDEE LAMB.
THE COWBOYS FACING WASHINGTON.
I HEARD THEY'RE BRINGING THEIR
OWN BENCHES TO WASHINGTON TO BE
MORE COMFORTABLE IN WASHINGTON.
I LIKE CEEDEE AND WE KNOW DAK
AND HIS WEAPONS.
HE WAS TRYING TO FIND CEEDEE.
I LIKE HIM SITTING AT PLUS 115.
CONNOR, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
>> I LIKE IT AS WELL.
DOUBLE DIGIT TARGETS FOR CEEDEE
LAMB LAST WEEK.
LET'S KEEP THAT MOVING
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE'S COMFORTABLE
IN THE SLOT AGAINST A WASHINGTON
DEFENSE THAT'S BANGED UP UP
FRONT, THE SECONDARY IS NOT VERY
GOOD RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T HATE WASHINGTON IN THAT
GAME BUT I THINK THEIR DEFENSE
WILL HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
I LOVE THE CEEDEE LAMB PICK.
THE RYAN TANNEHILL PICK, I KNOW
I'M A HATER HERE, BUT I'M COOL
ON THE RYAN TANNEHILL PICK.
WHERE ARE WE WITH THE COMMENTS
ON THIS ONE?
>> COOL ON THE PICK.
CONNOR, LET ME HOP INTO THE
COMMENTS.
LET ME SEE WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
OH, J.J. SNELL SAYS NEITHER.
SE
JERSEY OR BUST SAYS CEEDEE.
REX SAYS MY WIFE GOT THREE
DIFFERENT SAUCES ON MY TIE DYE,
NEED A NEW ONE.
THIS SAYS CEEDEE IS GOING FOR
100 YARDS PLUS TWO DECISIONS.
IT APPEARS THE COWBOY'S LEGEND,
CEEDEE LAMB IS MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND.
>> IT'S A WRAP.
EASY ROUND ONE.
ROUNDS TWO AND THREE, I DON'T
THINK THEY'LL BE THAT EASY TO
DECIDE.
OUR NEXT PITCH IS FROM "THE
SQUAD RIDE" VETERAN, W.
TRAMMELL.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE FOR US THIS
WEEK?
>> WHAT'S UP, B/R NATION.
THIS IS LUCY, SHE SAID IF WE
GIVE HER SOME WAFFLES FOR
BREAKFAST, SHE WOULD GIVE US A
LOCK.
WHICH ONE?
WHO IS IT?
TYREEK HILL.
LOCK IT IN
>> LUCY GOING WITH TYREEK HILL.
TAKING HER TIME, MAKING SURE SHE
GOT THE RIGHT WAFFLES.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN A DOG BE THAT
PATIENT AROUND GOOD FOOD IN MY
LIFE.
I LIKE THE PICK.
IT'S MINUS MONEY.
WE HAVE TWO WIDE RECEIVERS ON
THE BOARD RIGHT NOW.
WE KNOW CEEDEE YOU CAN BOOST
THAT THROUGH THE ROOF.
TYREEK HILL CAN DO SOME DAMAGE.
THIS IS A MORE JUICY MATCH-UP
HERE, GREG.
>> YES.
YES.
REAL JUICY MATCH-UP.
I NEED YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND LET ME KNOW WHICH
WAY WE SHOULD RIDE.
SHOULD WE RIDE WITH TYREEK HILL
OR CEEDEE LAMB.
CON
CONNOR, YOU SAW HOW LUCY
SCANNED, SHE SCANNED THE
WAFFLES, SHE SCANNED THE BUCKET,
SHE OBSERVED THE WAFFLES,
OBSERVED THE BUCKET, AND THEN
SHE WENT TO GO PICK WHICH ONE --
PICK THE WAFFLE SHE PICKED.
LANDED ON MY GUY, TYREEK HILL.
I SAID THAT BECAUSE I THINK
PATRICK MAHOMES IS GOING TO DO
THE SAME THING.
HE'S GOING TO SCAN THE FIELD,
OBSERVE THE FIELD AND THEN HE'S
GOING TO PICK APART THIS RAIDERS
DEFENSE.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, I LOVE THE
TYREEK HILL PLAY.
LOVE IT.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO
HERE.
IT'S MINUS 135.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO.
CONNOR, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
>> LUCY GOING OFF THE FIRST READ
AND THEN GOING WITH TYREEK HILL.
I THINK THE OFFENSE OF THE
CHIEFS IS IN FOR A BIG DAY.
THEY'RE BACK ON TRACK.
THE WINNING VIBES ARE BACK.
THE OFFENSE IS BACK.
WE KNOW TYREEK LIKES THEM IN
BUNCHES.
I'M FEELING THIS PICK.
AS MUCH AS I LOVE CEEDEE LAMB,
THEY'RE SPREADING THE BALL
AROUND A BIT, EVERYBODY IS BACK
ON THE FEED.
LET'S RELY ON THE PEOPLE TO
DECIDE ROUND TWO OF "THE SQUAD
RIDE" SHOW, WHICH DIRECTION ARE
THEY GOING IN?
>> I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
HERE WE GO.
E. BUGGERS HAS A CEEDEE GIF FOR
US.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LET'S SEND PRAYERS NOW.
IT'S SUNDAY.
LET'S SEND PRAYERS FOR THAT
RAIDERS DEFENSE BECAUSE PATRICK
MAHOMES AND TYREEK HILL IS GOING
TO CARVE THEM UP.
I'M CALLING IT.
>> IT'S A WRAP.
>> PUTTING MY FOOT DOWN AND
CALLING THE WAFFLE LEGEND,
TYREEK HILL, LUCY, AND W.
TRAMMELL IS MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND.
>> LUCY WITH THE BIG PICK, THE
BIG CROWN IN THE SECOND ROUND.
WE HAVE ONE MORE.
GOT TO DEFEAT THE FINAL
CONTENDER AND TAKE HOME THE
JERSEY, THE TITLE OF SQUAD RIDE.
GET YOUR PICK BOOSTED ON
DRAFTKINGS.
FINAL ROUND.
MATT O'NEILL AND JAY, I HEARD
HE'S GOT SOMETHING CRAZY PLANNED
HERE.
LET'S SEE WHAT IT IS.
>> OH, YEAH.
IT'S THE MACHO MAN, RANDY SAVAGE
COMING AT YOU WITH THE CREAM OF
THE CROP TOP LOCK PICK OF THE
WEEK, BROTHER.
OH, YEAH!
IT'S A CORDARRELLE PATTERSON
TOUCHDOWN.
LOCK IT IN, BOYS.
>> OH, YEAH, BROTHER.
CORDARRELLE PATTERSON COMING ON
THE BOARD AT MINUS 130.
OH, YEAH.
AGAINST TYREEK HILL.
WAFFLE LEGEND, MACHO MAN LEGEND.
THIS IS LIKE LAST ROUND, FANTASY
STARS, C.P. HAS BEEN SAVING HIS
TEAM AND MYSELF INCLUDED.
IS THIS ENOUGH TO KNOCK OFF
TRAMMELL?
>> THIS IS TOUGH, CONNOR.
THIS IS TOUGH.
WE HAVE CORDARRELLE PATTERSON
WHO HAS BEEN KILLING IT IN
FANTASY.
RUNNING BACK, WIDE RECEIVER,
WIDE RECEIVER, RUNNING BACK.
WE ALSO GOT TYREEK HILL.
I MENTIONED WHAT PATRICK MAHOMES
WILL DO TO THAT RAIDERS DEFENSE.
THIS IS TOUGH.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHICH WAY TO
GO.
I'LL BE HONEST.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
AFTER YOU GO, I'LL GO WITH THE
PEOPLE.
>> WE'LL NEED THEM, NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT.
I LIKE TYREEK HILL'S MATCH-UP.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT C.P., HE'S
GOING AGAINST A DEFENSE THAT HAS
HELD RUNNING BACKS IN CHECK FROM
A FANTASY PERSPECTIVE, FROM A
SCORING PERSPECTIVE.
HE DOES IT ALL.
HE CAN PLAY RECEIVER.
HE QUACATCHES OUT OF THE BACK FD
BUT I FEEL GOOD ABOUT TYREEK.
I KNOW THE COMMENTS WERE JUMPING
OFF.
THE ODDS ARE ALMOST EVEN.
I WILL ROLL WITH TYREEK HERE.
LET'S LET THE COMMENTS IN THE
B/R BETTING SECTION DECIDE THE
SQUAD RIDE LEADER FOR THIS WEEK.
>> CONNOR, I'M IN HERE FOR NEW
PEOPLE TO THE SHOW.
THIS IS THE HANDY DANDY iPAD,
THIS IS HOW YOU GET YOUR
HOODIES.
ALBERT 15 SAYS GIVE IT TO MY
BOY, TRAMMELL.
I'M THINKING ABOUT GIVING IT TO
TRAMMELL.
LOVE THE TYREEK HILL PLAY.
A.S. JEFF SAYS HILL GREATER THAN
PATTERSON.
FLEX SIGN THERE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT DANNY RODRIGUEZ WHO SAYS
C. PAT.
DEFINITELY A TOSS-UP.
DEFINITELY IS A TOSS-UP.
I HAVE SIMON HOUSTON, SIMON
HUDSON, SORRY, NOPE, TYREEK ALL
DAY, CONNOR.
I'M GOING TO CALL IT RIGHT
THERE.
I WILL CALL IT RIGHT THERE.
WE ARE RIDING WITH THE WAFFLE
LEGEND AND TYREEK HILL AND LUCY.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, LET'S JUST
CALL MY GUY W. TRAMMELL A SQUAD
RIDE HALL OF FAMER.
HE DESERVES TO BE HUNG IN THE
RAFTERS.
FROM NOW ON WE'RE REFERRING TO
HIM AS THE HALL OF FAMER.
AS THE HALL OF FAMER, MY GUY W.
TRAMMELL, WE'RE RIDING WITH
TYREEK HILL.
LET ME SHOW YOU THIS GRAPHIC SO
I CAN SHOW YOU WHAT WE CAN DO
HERE ON "THE SQUAD RIDE."
YOU SEE THE GRAPHIC.
IT SAYS TYREEK HILL MINUS 135.
POOF.
THERE IT IS.
THAT'S THE MAGIC THAT I'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS AT
DRAFTKINGS, WE'LL BOOST THAT
FROM MINUS 135 TO PLUS 135.
SEND US YOUR SCREEN SHOTS OF
YOUR BETS, SEND US YOUR VIDEOS
AND YOUR CELEBRATIONS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, CONNOR, WE
WANT WINNERS AND WINNERS ONLY,
PLEASE.
>> A BEAUTIFUL SIGHT TO SEE ALL
THE WAY UP.
PLUS 135, TYREEK HILL TO GET IN
THE END ZONE.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT TO DO.
WE'RE NOT DONE, THOUGH.
WE HAVE MORE LOCKS.
GREG HAS MORE HOODIES.
AND ONE MORE NFL JERSEY TO GIVE
AWAY.
YOU KNOW IF YOU STICK AROUND,
USUALLY YOU MAKE OUT WELL.
COMMUNITY COMMENT CONTEST TIME.
TALKING NFL MVP RACE ACTION
RIGHT NOW.
WE ASKED YOU IF YOU HAD TO PUT
$100 ON SOMEONE TO WIN THE MVP
RIGHT NOW, WHO WOULD IT BE?
THERE'S A RUNAWAY FAVORITE AT
THE TOP.
A GUY THAT Y'ALL KNOW WELL IN
TOM BRADY.
THEN A DROPOFF TO AARON RODGERS,
KYLER MURRAY, ANOTHER DROPOFF TO
DAK PRESCOTT, PATRICK MAHOMES,
MATTHEW STAFFORD AND THE ONLY
RUNNING BACK ON THE BOARD IN
J.T., JONATHAN TAYLOR.
WHILE THIS LOOKS LIKE A RUNAWAY,
IT'S ALL STILL PLUS MONEY.
THERE'S SOME ROOM FOR THIS RACE
TO TIGHTEN UP.
WE PICKED OUR FAVORITE TWO
COMMENTS, WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOU THINK.
GREG, WHAT DID WE GET THIS WEEK
FROM THE COMMENT SECTION ON THE
MVP RACE?
>> I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH
OF THESE IS THE BETTER TAKE.
I AM GIVING AWAY A HOODIE.
THE FIRST COMMENT IS FROM THE
G.O.A.T.
T.B.
THERE'S NO BIAS HERE.
BRADY IS THE ONLY 44-YEAR-OLD ON
PACE FOR 5,300 YARDS AND 48
TOUCHDOWNS WITH THE 9-3 TEAM
ABOUT TO WIN THE DIVISION FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 14 YEARS.
BUT Y'ALL ARE HATERS --
>> HATERS!
>> IN TRYING TO GIVE THE AWARD
TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
G.O.A.T. T.B., WE ARE NOT HATERS
ON "THE SQUAD RIDE."
WE SHOW LOVE AND AN ABUNDANCE OF
LOVE ON "THE SQUAD RIDE."
I LIKE TOM BRADY TO WIN THE MVP.
IF EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED IN
THE SEASON CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN -- HE DOESN'T GET
INJURED, I SEE HIM CLEARLY
WALKING AWAY WITH THE MVP
TROPHY.
CONNOR, ARE YOU A HATER?
>> I'M NOT A TOM BRADY HATER,
ESPECIALLY SINCE HE LEFT NEW
ENGLAND.
THAT MADE LIFE EASIER HERE IN
THE NORTHEAST.
FOR REAL, NO HATERS.
NO HATING HERE.
LOOK AT THE STATS.
THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
LOOKING AT THE G.O.A.T. T.B.
ACCOUNT, I WONDER IF TOM BRADY
IS ON HIS BURNER FLOW HERE.
THIS IS A LITTLE SUSPECT.
LISTEN, HE'S THE FAVORITE AT THE
TOP OF THE BOARD FOR A REASON.
IF HE KEEPS IT ON CRUISE
CONTROL, HE WILL WIN THIS THING.
I'M NOT HATING AT ALL.
I'M SURE THE COMMENTS AGREE THIS
IS TOM BRADY'S AWARD TO LOSE,
RIGHT?
>> LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
THERE'S NO HATING ON THIS SIDE.
I DON'T SEE ANY HATES IN THE
COMMENT.
B/R BETTING IN THE COMMENTS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
DANNY RODRIGUEZ SAYS HE DESERVES
IT.
A TOM BRADY GIF OF HIM SMILING.
GOT LOCK IT UP SAYING AARON
RODGERS.
>> MAYBE.
>> YOHE GOT A GIF WITH AARON
RODGERS.
LET'S DISCUSS THE NEXT COMMENT
FROM BRI GUY.
HE SAYS JONATHAN TAYLOR IS
SITTING AT 1,348 YARDS AND 16
TOUCHDOWNS WITH FOUR GAMES TO
GO.
I THINK HE COULD GO OFF DOWN THE
STRETCH AND GET THE COACH TO THE
PLAYOFFS.
PLUS 1600 AIN'T A BAD BET AT
ALL.
I LIKE THE WISHFUL THINKING.
MY MAN, HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO GO
BONKERS.
HE'LL HAVE TO GO BONKERS AND
CRAZY.
TOM BRADY IS SITTING AT PLUS
1600 FOR A REASON.
I'M NOT HATING.
I'M JUST SAYING MY GUY WILL HAVE
TO GO OUT THERE AND PUT ON AN
ABSOLUTE SHOW TO STEAL THIS FROM
TOM BRADY.
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THE TAKE IS RIGHT, RIGHT?
HE'S RIGHT OVER THERE.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
LOOK AT WHAT J.T. HAS DONE.
THEY DIDN'T GIVE DEREK HENRY
LOVE WHEN HE WAS DOING THIS OR
DOING THIS AT A HIGHER LEVEL.
WHY ARE THEY GOING TO CHANGE
NOW?
IT SHOWS THE AWARD IS BROKEN.
IT'S A BROKEN SYSTEM.
THE PLUS 1600 TO ME IS A SUCKER
BET.
YOU SAY JONATHAN TAYLOR SHOULD
BE THE MVP OR A TOP MVP
CANDIDATE.
THE ODDS ARE PLUS 1600.
MAYBE I CAN MAKE A QUICK BUCK
HERE.
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
IT'S THE VOTING SYSTEM FOR THE
AWARD IS BROKEN, JUST LIKE THE
HEISMAN.
IT'S AN AWARD THAT GENERALLY
GOES TO QUARTERBACKS, GUYS THAT
ARE THE FACE OF THAT FRANCHISE.
THIS AWARD HAS NOT BEEN WON BY A
RUNNING BACK SINCE 2012 WITH
ADRIAN PETERSON WHEN HE WAS THE
BIGGEST FREAK IN THE LEAGUE.
IT'S TOUGH.
IT'S NOT REALISTIC.
I HATE TO BE THE BAD GUY THERE.
THE MVP HAS BECOME MOST VALUABLE
QUARTERBACK NOT MOST VALUABLE
FOOTBALL PLAYER.
THAT'S THE ISSUE.
>> CONNOR, YOU HAVE A FAIR POINT
AND THE STATISTICS TO BACK IT
UP.
YOU BROUGHT OUT STATISTICS FOR
THE MVP RACE.
WE HAVE D. BOY 22 IN THE
COMMENTS WHO SAYS -- CONNOR,
HE'S PREACHING WHAT YOU PREACH.
HE SAYS IF DEREK HENRY DIDN'T
GET 2,000 YARDS, NO WAY J.T.
DOES THIS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, D. BOY 22.
YOU'RE WAKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
GO WHITE SOX, YOU CAN SEE IT
THERE, J.T., LET'S GET IT.
ROCKING WITH J.T.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
LOOK AT GO WHITE SOX IN THE
COMMENTS AGAIN.
T.J. WATT DESERVES SOME MVP
VOTES.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
BRI GUY, GOING WITH BRI GUY
HERE.
I WILL GIVE BRI GUY A HOODIE.
YOU ARE THE WINNER OF THE
COMMENTS CONTEST.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, BROTHER.
>> GREG, BEFORE WE GET TO OUR
BOLDEST BETS, LET'S TALK PLAYER
PROPS FROM THIS WEEKEND'S SLATE.
IT'S A GOOD SLATEMENT WE HAVE
SOME GUYS GETTING HEALTHY AT THE
RIGHT TIME OF THE YEAR.
SO, NEED SOME HELP FROM THE
SQUAD.
YOU DECIDE IF IT'S A LOCK OR A
DROP.
GREG, TELL THEM WHAT WE GOT.
>> GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL
ME IF THESE PROPS ARE A LOCK OR
IF WE NEED TO DROP THEM
IMMEDIATELY.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES TO
WHOEVER CAN HELP US OUT.
CHECK OUT THE PROP.
ALVIN KAMARA OVER OR UNDER 69.5
RUSHING YARDS.
THIS IS HIS FIRST GAME BACK
SINCE WEEK NINE.
MARK INGRAM IS OUT TODAY, WHICH
WILL GIVE KAMARA THE WORK LOAD.
DO YOU LIKE THE OVER OR DO YOU
LIKE THE UNDER?
>> I LOVE THE OVER.
THE JETS RUN DEFENSE DOES NOT
EXIST.
IT'S NOT REAL.
IT'S NOT A THING.
THEY CAN'T STOP ANYONE ON THE
GROUND.
TAYSOM HILL WILL EAT SOME OF
THOSE YARDS BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
THROW FRANKLY AND HE WON'T NEED
TO TODAY.
THEY CAN RUN ON THE JETS.
THE ONE CONCERN IS TAYSOM GETS A
LOT OF THOSE CARRIES OR THEY
WANT TO MODERATE KAMARA.
KAMARA ALMOST PLAYED TEN DAYS
AGO.
IT CAME DOWN TO A GAMETIME
DECISION.
HE HAD TEN MORE DAYS.
HE SHOULD BE 100% HEALTHY, READY
TO GO, READY TO BE THAT
WORKHORSE BACK AGAINST A GREAT
MATCH-UP FOR HIM.
YOU KNOW ME, I DON'T LIKE
RUSHING TOTAL OVERS.
I LIKE THIS ONE A LOT.
>> CONNER LIOR LIKES IT.
THE SAINTS ARE FACING CONNOR'S
TEAM.
>> NO BIAS HERE.
>> HE'S TELLING YOU GUYS THAT
KAMARA WILL RUSH FOR OVER 69.5
AGAINST HIS OWN TEAM.
THAT SHOULD TELL YOU SOMETHING.
I'M ALSO GOING TO PIGGYBACK WITH
YOU.
I THINK KAMARA IS GOING TO GO
OVER HERE.
HE'S GOING TO BE THE GUY TODAY.
HE'S GOING TO BE THE GUY.
NO MARK INGRAM.
THEY CAN'T REALLY THROW THE
BALL.
THEY'LL HAVE TO RUN IT.
ONE RUN CAN POP THIS.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE OVER.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PROP.
BEFORE I DO THAT, YOU KNOW WHAT
I GOT TO DO.
IT'S CHRISTMAS SEASON.
I HAVE TO GIVE AWAY SOME
HOODIES.
LET ME GIVE AWAY ONE.
I GOT HAYDEN BOWERS.
I THINK I GAVE YOU A HOODIE
ALREADY.
HAYDEN BOWERS SAYS A MINIMUM OF
150 YARDS.
ALSO TANNEHILL RUSHING TD, BOOK
IT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
W. TRAMMELL IS IN THE COMMENTS.
HE'S ON THE SHOW, ALSO IN THE
COMMENTS.
THERE HE IS THERE.
OVER, OVER, OVER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
LET'S MOVE ON.
NEXT PROP, KYLER MURRAY.
KYLER MURRAY TO THROW OVER OR
UNDER 263.5 PASSING YARDS?
HAD FOUR TOTAL TOUCHDOWNS LAST
WEEK.
RUSHED IN TWO, THREW FOR TWO.
THREW FOR 123 YARDS LAST WEEK,
CONNER.
LAST TIME THE CARDINALS PLAYED
THE RAMS IN WEEK FOUR, MURRAY
HAD THE BEST GAME OF HIS CAREER.
SO, TALK TO ME, CONNOR.
DO YOU LIKE THIS?
DO YOU LIKE THE OVER?
I'LL GO FIRST.
I JUST WANT TO -- HE HAD 123
LAST WEEK.
NOW WE'RE SITTING AT 263 AGAINST
THIS RAMS DEFENSE?
I JUST DON'T KNOW IF KYLER
MURRAY IS FULLY HEALTHY.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S FULLY
HEALTHY.
I KNOW HE WENT FOR FOUR
TOUCHDOWNS, RAN FOR TWO.
263 IS A LOT FOR ME AFTER
THROWING FOR 123.
>> GREG, THEY ASKED HIM TO THROW
15 TIMES LAST GAME.
YOU HAVE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FACT THAT IT'S NOT THAT
KYLER MURRAY IS NOT THAT GOOD OR
HE WON'T BE A STUD THIS WEEK,
NOT ANY HATE ON THE CARDINALS.
IT'S THE FACT THAT THEY DON'T
NEED HIM TO COME OUT AND DO
THIS.
THEY DON'T NEED HIM TO COME OUT
AND THROW FOR 300 PLUS YARDS
EVERY WEEK.
WHAT HE CAN DO WITH HIS LEGS.
THEY HAVE JAMES CONNER IN THE
BACKFIELD.
THEY'RE GETTING CHASE EDMONDS
BACK, THEIR PASS CATCHING
RUNNING BACK.
I LOOK AT THIS GAME AND GO, MAN,
MAYBE SOME PEOPLE THINK SHOOTOUT
AGAINST THE RAMS.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT'S NOT
THAT HE'S NOT TALENTED ENOUGH TO
DO THIS OR GOOD ENOUGH RIGHT
NOW, IT'S THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY -- IT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE IT'S THERE.
THESE ARE TRADITIONALLY ONES
THAT I STAY AWAY FROM BECAUSE OF
THE UNPREDICTABLE NATURE OF THIS
DIVISION MATCH-UP.
IF I HAD TO GO, I WOULD STAY
AWAY FROM THE OVER.
I WOULD HIT THE UNDER ON THIS
ONE.
>> CONNOR IS HITTING THE UNDER.
I'M HITTING THE UNDER.
I'M SEEING WHAT THEY'RE HITTING.
JESSE 24 SAYS UNDER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> I LOVE THAT.
>> 263 IS A LOT.
I AGREE.
LOCK IT UP.
263 IS A LOT.
J. LAWSON IS TELLING US BLESS
UP.
BLESS UP TO YOU, MY BROTHER.
HERE, MURRAY IS GETTING THE
UNDER DUE TO THE COMMENTS JUST
MADE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU ALL, YOU'RE
GETTING A HOODIE.
>> WE HAVE TO DO OUR BOLDEST
BETS OF THE WEEK.
WE'VE BEEN HAVING SOME FUN WITH
THIS ONE.
GREG, WHAT DO WE NEED FROM THE
PEOPLE HERE?
>> I NEED YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND RIDE CONNOR'S
PARLAY.
IT HIT LAST WEEK.
I LIKE IT THIS WEEK AGAIN.
CONNOR, TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT
YOUR PARLAY IS RIGHT NOW.
>> I HIT A LONG SLUMP, BUT WE'RE
BACK.
WE'RE HOT.
STARTING A NEW STREAK HERE.
IF IT'S NOT BROKEN, DON'T FIX
IT.
ANOTHER UNDERDOG PARLAY, PLUS
395.
RAVENS UNDER DOGS GOING TO
CLEVELAND AGAINST THOSE BROWNS.
OKAY.
YEAH.
LET'S JUMP ON THE RAVENS HERE,
MONEY LINE.
FALCONS UPSETTING THE REELING
PANTHERS RIGHT NOW.
WE TALKED ABOUT CORDARRELLE
PATTERSON EARLIER IN THE SHOW.
HERE IT IS.
TWO TEAMS, TWO UPSET WINS.
WORKED LAST WEEK.
LET'S RUN IT BACK.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING THIS WEEK?
>> I WANT TO ADMIRE YOUR PARLAY.
I LOVE THAT YOU'RE DOING THESE
UNDERDOGS PARLAYS.
I RODE YOUR ONE FROM LAST WEEK
AND I'M RIDING IT AGAIN THIS
WEEK.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, WE TALKED
ABOUT TYREEK HILL.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHIC, IT'S
RIGHT THERE.
I'M GOING WITH TYREEK HILL TO
SCORE TWO OR MORE TOUCHDOWNS
AGAINST THAT RAIDERS DEFENSE.
THIS IS SOLELY BECAUSE THEY'RE
PLAYING THE RAIDERS.
PATRICK MAHOMES HAD A GREAT GAME
THE FIRST TIME THEY PLAYED THE
RAIDERS.
IF IT AIN'T BROKE, CONNOR, DON'T
FIX IT.
YOU DON'T THINK HE'LL DOUBLE
BACK AND HAVE A GOOD GAME THIS
WEEK?
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU DO, BUT I
DO.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, HIS
FAVORITE TARGET, ONE OF HIS
FAVORITES, I LIKES TRAVIS KELCE,
TOO, BUT ONE OF HIS FAVORITE
TARGETS IS TYREEK HILL.
TYREEK HILL LIKES TO SCORE
TOUCHDOWNS IN BUNCHES.
I'M ROCKING WITH TYREEK HILL,
TWO TOUCHDOWNS OR MORE.
LET'S GO, PATRICK MAHOMES AND
TYREEK HILL.
>> I LOVE THIS.
HE DID IT AGAINST THE RAIDERS
LAST TIME, TWO TOUCHDOWNS.
WHY NOT DO IT AGAIN?
THEY DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
HIM IN THEIR SECONDARY RIGHT
NOW.
I LIKE WHERE YOUR HEAD IS AT
RIGHT THERE.
PLUS 400.
JUMP ON THE BOLDEST BETS.
BEFORE WE LEAVE YOU, THE
COMMENTS HAVE TO LET US KNOW ARE
THEY GOING WITH THE UNDERDOG
PARLAY OR TYREEK WITH TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
YOU SHOULD GO WITH ONE AND WHY
NOT GO WITH TWO.
YOU HAVE ONE MORE NFL JERSEY TO
GIVE AWAY BEFORE WE GET OUT OF
HERE.
>> YES, SIR.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
OH, MY BOY MATT DODGER IS IN THE
COMMENTS.
MATT DODGER, HE SAYS LET'S GO
GREGMENT  MEN
GREG.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
MATT DODGER ALSO COMMENTED
EARLIER.
I SAW WHAT HE SAID EARLIER.
HE MENTIONED TOM BRADY WINNING
MVP.
LOVE THAT TAKE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
JERSEY.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
I GOT CONNOR'S STREAK COMING
AWAY TO AN END.
BIG MIKE RIDING WITH CONNOR.
I'M RIDING WITH CONNOR, TOO.
LOVE THOSE UNDERDOGS.
THERE IT IS.
BIG MIKE 13, YOU ARE ALSO
WALKING AWAY -- HOLD ON.
G. QUINN RIGHT ABOVE HIM.
I LIKE THAT PLUS MONEY.
I'M GOING TO RIDE IT WITH YOU.
CONNOR, YOU'RE GETTING FANS.
>> I GOT SOME LOVE.
>> FANS IN THE COMMENT SECTION.
THEY LOVE YOU.
I LOVE YOUR PARLAY, TOO.
SEND THAT TO ME.
AFTER THE SHOW, SEND ME YOUR
PARLAY, I'M PUTTING IT ON THE
B/R BETTING STORY.
>> I'M IN THE LETTING YOU GET
OUT OF HERE WITHOUT GIVING THE
JERSEY AWAY.
>> MATT DODGER.
HE MENTIONED TOM BRADY WINS AN
MVP AND THE TWO TOUCHDOWNS FOR
TYREEK HILL.
MATT DODGER, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH THAT JERSEY.
>> YOU HEARD IT.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR WAGERS
TODAY.
CONGRATS TO ALL OUR HOODIE AND
JERSEY WINNERS.
IF YOU WON, B/R BETTING WILL DM
YOU WITHIN THE NEXT 24 HOURS.
THANKS TO OUR LEGENDS, AND ENJOY
THE GAMES TODAY, EVERYBODY.
DROP YOUR REALTIME TAKES IN THE
SPORTS BETTING COMMUNITY STREAM
IN THAT "BLEACHER REPORT" APP.
FOLLOW GREG ON THOSE STORIES ALL
DAY.
THERE'S RUMORS I'LL JUMP IN
THERE AS WELL AND GIVE THAT
PARLAY OUT.
ALONGSIDE THE MAN, GREG IVORY,
I'M CONNOR ROGERS, SEE Y'ALL
NEXT TIME, SAME TIME, SAME
PLACE.
♪